[Musique]
ce mercredi 18 novembre cyrille melchior
président du département et maurice
gironcel président de la cinor ont signé
une convention de partenariat dans le
cadre du contrat d'objectifs déchets
économie circulaire des objectifs du
département de la cinor se rejoignent
autour de plusieurs champs de compétence
cette convention que nous avons signée
nous permettre de mutualiser nos
expériences de nous appuyer bien sûr sur
les services haussier de la cinor et de
mutualiser nos moyens en terme de
protection environnementale donc sur le
plan technique d'abord mutualiser les
moyens c'est réduire les coûts c'est
aussi bénéficier des expériences des uns
et des autres en termes de développement
des énergies renouvelables
et comme je le dis aussi donc de
préservation à travers la lutte contre
les déchets ici à la rédac la signature
de la convention a été suivie de la
visite du chantier de l'arbre solaire
réalisé par une entreprise locale en
cours d'installation dans la cour du
palais de la source
il voulait quelque chose d'innovant pour
la collectivité et donc nous na
on est parti sur un cahier des charges
sur la réalisation d'une structure qui
s'apparente plus ou moins tronc d'arbre
avec des panneaux dessus pour pouvoir
alimenter les cellules pour pouvoir
politique hull électrique
tous les ans des acquisitions
obligatoire et de 1.52 m'ont même
nous devons acquérir 20% de notre flotte
et en 2021 ce sera 30 passant donc les
obligations vont évoluer
et pour répondre différemment volet de
brancher sur le réseau électrique
nous avons voulu créer notre propre
structure autonome qui va alimenter nos
véhicules électriques cet arbre solaire
est une première dans l'océan indien il
sera opérationnel à partir du 16
décembre
[Musique]